but that was my you know that was my
foray and that was how I started
everything was like I had so many I
wasn't like a prop comic but I did a lot
of [__] that like involved one of the
bits I did that got sort of viral not
hugely viral but back in the day it was
a bit about going to a gay gym and
turning gay again I did the shirt flip
and I would pull out like a red thong
strap and you have to wear it every day
like going going to the open mic here we
go so the worst is like you know you're
in like Topeka and you're at a Walmart
looking for thongs for your show and
you're in your 30s you're like what the
[__] have I done with my life my breath
what is goody hot breath the verse
welcome back to Hot Breath the show
where you learn comedy from the pros I'm
your host comedian Joel Byers and after
over 400 interviews on this show we
talked to comedians about how they got
to where they were and where they are to
help comedians upcoming do the same and
our guest today has gone on a whole path
diversity in his comedy from doing not
just stand up but acting he's done
Broadway he also does Jujitsu so he's
one of these comedians that you can
learn from that diversifies his skill
sets Beyond just I want to be a comedian
so without further Ado hop Brethren and
sister and welcome to the show Mr Bill
dolls everyone give it up hey hey for us
we're here thanks for having me Joel of
course thanks for being here yeah and
thank you for the intro made me
something cool you are cool man you've
done a lot I think sometimes comedians
we do stand up and we feel like we can
only do stand-ups so it's great to talk
to someone who actually branches out
Beyond just like get on stage right
jokes get on stage hate myself get on
stage right jokes like you look for a
lot of other creative Outlets well it's
funny because I feel like my experience
because I started off as an actor right
I went to graduate school for acting my
experience is that Comics are generally
a little bit smarter
than most people
and I think that Comics kind of sell
themselves short like I think most
Comics can kind of do anything there's a
lot of different revenues like when your
talented limbo this way you could be a
talented comic
like Ali Wong and all of a sudden you
know become an actress that could win an
Emmy
after never even acted before because I
think this the skills that you acquire
from from Stand Up are just
they're so well-rounded they're you know
there's you got to be intellectual you
gotta like problem solve you gotta be on
your feet with crowds when they're
heckling you you gotta be funny and
Charming on top of it and most of all
you gotta be likable so I think it's
sort of and as an actor you just got to
go up there and just say [__] this
almost wrote which ultimately is like
it's pretty easy if you just get your if
you wrap your head around it you know
what I mean I know a lot of comics
historically have gone on to sets and
they're like I I gotta I gotta [__] with
the line let me change but you all you
gotta do is just sit there and relax and
breathe and just say a line as an actor
it's really [__] easy I hate to say
it I just did a show this is gonna be a
name drop
Alaska Daily was a show with Hilary
Swank and she's won [__] two Oscars
and she just you know she's pregnant she
had covid she's got a lot of [__] in her
mind she's just like where are my lines
and then she says her lines
says are lines I'm like do you even
really I mean she's great don't get me
wrong yeah she's got a great face for
camera but like you can literally not
give a [__]
as an actor and kill it
how can comedians break into acting well
I mean that's I mean I think that most
first of all just all you gotta do is
just get incredibly famous as a comic
that's all you got to do okay then once
you're incredibly famous as a comic
I will say this I started doing a um I
started doing like audition coaching for
a lot of comics because it was happening
I was discovering a lot of like New York
Comics that were getting kind of big
they were uh they'd get like rep by CA
or ICM one of the big guys
and they're like okay we're going to
make you a star and they'd come to LA
and they'd get an audition for like a
sitcom or wherever it is
and they'd never auditioned before
so their agent or managers you got to
work with Ivana chubbock I know it's 300
an hour for an audition for an audition
coaching do you understand how crazy
that you're paying 300 to some fat [__]
to sit there and tell you the choices
because I these I [__] hate these
people I hate The Cult of like acting
coaches and acting teachers they're just
so there's one guy that was just like
literally like before that you start
don't give them eye contact I'm like
what the [__] are you talking about dude
this is David Letterman and like you
can't wear perfumes you said shut up but
I did it it was 250 I went to this one
guy and remember he gave me one choice
for this for this audition for like
Entourage and it was like an okay choice
but I paid 200 for a choice I didn't get
the part it just made me realize like
it's a [__] scam they're they're
tricking these young kids off the bus
from [__] Wichita whatever it is I'm
gonna make it big mama give me the bus
ticket I'm out of here and they show up
and like well if you want to make it big
you got to work with these three
multi-millionaires who are going to
[__] fleece you dry for all your
hard-working pay at goddamn Applebee's
or Cheesecake Factory if you're working
at the Grove and then you go up there
and it that will never book your role I
would love to hear a story of someone's
like you know what I was down out I was
living in my car but I paid 300 to Ivana
just um coaching comics
because it's mostly just you know just
comfortable talking and saying saying
other people's lines and actually
believing what you're saying that's all
it [__] is so
um and I booked some comics on series I
mean Emma wilman's one of them she'd
never auditioned before that's great
she's great and she you know I work with
her a bunch
so I I and I you know it's like whatever
just pay me whatever you can like we're
we should be a community we should be
helping each other I'm not gonna charge
like I'm not even gonna charge a hundred
dollars like hey give me 60 50 bucks for
an hour it's fine you know yeah yeah and
that's that's what this whole show and
the community that especially boomed
over the pandemic when none of us had
stage time and we all just kind of went
online and this the show turned into
like an online community that's around
the world now of just Comics helping
Comics so that's really cool people like
you as well like paying it forward like
that yeah well I mean they still pay me
okay no I mean paying it like you're
giving them access to information that
otherwise maybe well I just got so mad
when com because I Feel Like Comics are
very sense of people they're very
vulnerable the business is very
unforgiving and I think a lot of people
will literally like just throw hundreds
and hundreds of dollars away to this
idea that this one person is going to be
you know it's going to make you a
Hollywood star and it's [__] I mean they
used to do that back in the day with
managers where like I think you're
amazing you're gonna be a star just pay
me five thousand dollars a month they
used to charge people it's the biggest
scam [__] ever it's completely it's
completely immoral and illegal probably
now uh so yeah I don't have a lot of uh
it's not like I don't have respect for
acting I do because they're great actors
and I like to think that I'm pretty good
but um but I also know that there's a
lot of people just punching the clock
and punching out and I feel with stand
up the difference is is that we're
always striving
even I mean I know comics in their 70s
like ah man I gotta work on this bit oh
I got this pitch next week I'm like dude
you're 80 years old you got a pitch but
that's [__] amazing you know what I
mean that's like we're great we're all
we live in this world of complete
delusion that we're somehow Gonna Change
the World and we're somehow gonna you
know our comedy is gonna make a
difference and that's a beautiful thing
I really mean that but actor said man I
don't know I feel like acting as a
acting's changed you know I think it's
kind of like
it's more about the 401K and the pension
and the insurance and like making sure
you pay for your kids soccer gear and
[__] like that but you you could also
say the same for comedy that now it's
more about the crowd work clip how to go
viral that's true it's not about like oh
let me get as good as as possible at
this and really kind of climb my way
people see like Nate bargatzi selling
out Arenas now but they don't realize it
was over 20 years in the making of
course so they're like oh if I go viral
I can sell out and then boom and it's
all crowd work clips and things like
that so comedy has really that is true
that is true and and as much as I hate
that I'm trying to get that crap yeah
you're getting we're all like this one
Michael viral no ah [__] but now if
someone like you or I goes viral we're
like ready and we can do stand up 100
and we could back it up when they come
see us that there is a headliner set
behind this 30 second crowd work don't
you think though I can't believe it was
just a copy copy that was very active
like a TV Guide Jesus Christ so uh but
don't you think like stand-up is kind of
like a self-regulating industry in the
sense that if you do that if you get the
clip it gets like 20 million views and
then it makes you a headliner and you go
out there and you eat a dick don't you
think it's kind of like well we can't
have you back anymore because you
[__] suck yeah I think like I'll give
you an example of someone who I really
like like Trevor Wallace you know when
he started
um he was kind of a lot of people wanted
to talk [__] about him because he was
doing sketches that [__] put in
the work he worked his ass off and I'm
sure when he started his first headline
gigs he may have been a little bit
underprepared but he actually was
humbled about it and he worked his butt
off and now he's he's one of the biggest
comics in the [__] world right now
it's amazing you know and he's really
good and he works pretty much clean and
I'm [__] jealous of that guy [__] him
no he's great he's awesome he's awesome
he's great is that are you bitter now is
that what no no no not really I actually
I think I've won a few Comics I don't
have a I don't care how you get into it
if you get like
um if you become a massive headliner
because of TV film a video clip or
whatever the [__] it is you've made a
porn I don't care like as long as you
show up and you work hard and you treat
people okay I don't care like you can't
get mad at someone you know I worked
with um I still work with like Jeremy
pivot a lot of people were like well
he's taking shortcuts to get where he
he's at he's like well you can call the
shortcut but he's also been like a child
doctor since age seven hmm you know what
I mean working on stage and working in
comedy he's done like 80 [__] TV
shows and movies like
it's okay that he maybe because he still
works his ass off as a comic
so I feel like I guess my point is I
feel like most Comics I know they're
doing well are always working I if
someone's phoning it in and we've all
been there where we phoned it in you go
up in a show and you're like you almost
feel like hit a tape recorder you're
just like you [__] hate yourself yeah
like for days like I can't believe I
just [__] didn't believe a word I
said I just went up there and just was
an autopilot
so but I feel like as an actor you can
really like make a career of just being
on autopilot I really do yeah I really
do I [__] hate it but you know that's
that's part of the job as a comedian is
you perform no matter what like if it's
five or five hundred people you really
have to perform as if it is like a sold
out crowd to really give everyone the
show and I've noticed that's the
difference between like a professional
and like an amateur is someone who can
turn it on regardless of the audience
and really give them a show yeah yeah
that's a good point I think that's
really true because I just did a yeah my
buddy Adam Hunter did uh he was like
look man
I got a show for you as a headlining gig
it's at Coolio's Social Club love it in
Pennsylvania
I was like Coolio has a social club in
apparently he partnered with this this
guy named Mike who's like total I'm for
lack of better word total white trash
and just hey my name's Mike I think he'd
spent time in prison but him Coolio were
buddies and they had a social club and
so I was like cool and they were gonna
pay like real money for this headlining
gig it's in the middle of it's outside
Pittsburgh
and then like we
were I was going there like okay we're
changing the venue to Mary's Place
I'm like what's Mary's place it's
literally a pub and Clearfield
Pennsylvania like a pub like TVs
probably like cathode ray TV it's not
even like a flat screen you know air in
the game [__] and you get there and
there's there's a big sign says you can
totally smoke here or like smoking is
legal
this is one of the few bars so everyone
you go and there's everyone's [__]
smoking Menthol and uh they all have
prison tats and you you get there and
the the place where they're the stage
and the venue
um there's probably like 30 people
and I just remember thinking like man
this is after [__] 16 years in this
game this is where I'm at 17 years now
this is where I'm at
I'm
at Mary's place in Clearfield going
before for 30 inmates you know
ex-inmates and uh
but I gotta tell you it was a great
[__] show and I think that yeah there
are Comics who who
judge the audience judge themselves
judged their career where they're at I
can't believe I'm doing this and I've
worked with some of these comics and
they really down themselves but the
point is like
everyone deserves to [__] laugh
everyone deserves a breath so so [__]
stupid everyone deserves a break come on
but like you gotta like yeah you gotta
go out there like there's no reason why
you wouldn't you don't want to give your
best show at all times there's never a
reason I've I performed at the Hollywood
Laugh Factory run for two people
it was like a late show and everyone had
left I don't know if I'd walked him or
not but yeah there's you were going to
be there there's just a couple just
sitting there and I just sat there for
30 minutes and just did
my show for them and it was I loved it
it's great it doesn't really matter the
size you know yeah I think also it's
some people will default to roasting the
audience or berating the audience for if
it's five people they're like oh make
fun of the audience they're like we came
to laugh like now we didn't come here to
ruin your night and then they take it
out on the audience yeah it's just it's
embarrassing yeah I've also completely
changed my mind about uh hecklers and
taking it out in the audience I just had
too many experiences
uh too many experiences where
um
there was some weird energy or heckling
energy and I kind of
went into it and I went into them
because you know Comics love that yeah
Comics love it when other Comics go
after the audience they're in the
backlits just jerking off so there's two
one moment was uh I was doing a show in
the Schamberg improv and it was like
this one's toward Jamie candy it was
packed it was like I don't know 40500
people
theirs is attractive woman in the front
row and I said I just made some comment
about like
she was single another woman I said
something like
I don't know I made some comment about
like
you're single because you know marriages
don't work or did you kill your husband
because you couldn't stand or something
like that her husband had died the week
before this is her first time out her
friend said come on out
it was really funny they were like
friends of mine who
she came out like I want to laugh for
the first time
I think it's been like three weeks first
of three weeks and I just went on about
a dead husband thing and at one point I
go
your husband didn't die did he and she
was just like
and I didn't know how to [__] I was too
green to figure out how to recover I
mean I wonder what I would say now
so because I think she'd made some
comment and I kind of went into her and
then there was another time it was at
the New York uh Laugh Factory when that
was there and they're these group of
people that were they were talking like
it was [__]
going back and I would go to the other
side of the room because one of those
like long wide rooms and they kept
talking I was hey guys guys just keep it
out for a little bit anyway
what the [__] are you guys [__]
[__] it was like a field trip I
swear my life it was like a sponsor with
like five like mentally handicapped
people that were there and they'd been
having like the time of their life this
is like their day out yep you know and
uh and they were lit and I was Furious
because I'm like nobody told me you can
blame it on someone else well there's
well they're able they're
they weren't just like a little off
it was like Harrison Ford it was more
like Ben Stiller and Tropic Thunder
it was a jack
if it was full you know what I'm saying
so um
and I look and then you look like you
know your eyes like zoom in and you
focus like I mean they're just like you
know uh you know some I don't know
extreme autism some that were just like
I think there was a guy with down terms
there
and they'd gone out for like a fun
little field trip and I called them a
bunch I said
what are you [__] and I felt so I
mean that was one of the worst feelings
I've ever had so now
I'm always just like man you never know
you never know who someone is what their
day is what they're going through so now
when people huckle me I just kind of I
just take it I don't care I don't get
mad at him because you never know
sometimes people are just
you know people should be always be
afforded dignity respect even if they
you don't think they deserve it at the
time
the the crowd all know that these people
are mentally handicapped I'm not gonna
drop the r word hey guys just so you
know uh there's gonna be a group there's
gonna be table in the front row no I
don't know yeah so they weren't all like
they just it all just goes in my head I
just saw it yeah I was only like 10
minutes into my set and I was perfect
[__] [__]
so there's just been moments like that
where people and people sometimes
heckling me like say something funny
dude of course and I have to show that
dude you're my favorite I'm like why did
you yell that yeah because I thought you
were funny I want you to say something
funny again I'm like oh Jesus do you
realize it's really how insecure we are
you can't do that but you came up doing
like the urban runes right like didn't
you do right because in Atlanta like
that's that's what I came is that he
came with the urban run I came up white
boy Joel oh that's so funny yeah so
that's that's why I think I'd heard that
you did a lot of urban rooms and one of
your business you would take your pants
off at one time I think that was another
thing you used to do holy [__] it was
so funny you said that because I used to
um
I usually this bit it's funny because I
saw Dave Chappelle do a similar bit like
one of his early and I was like I don't
think I stole that
I think it was just a bit I was always
obsessed with superheroes parallel
thoughts are real but the bit was
basically um his whole bit about
superheroes
I forgot what it was but there was one
about Wonder Woman
and I said uh
and the joke was something like
look if you're Wonder Woman and you're
like evading she had the invisible plane
I go what's more conspicuous if you're
like trying to I forget what's more
inconspicuous like a little Cessna
flying through the sky or women with
double D cups and Star Spangled hot
pants in midair like this and I ripped
my pants off
I like flipped my shirt like like you
know like something like this I flip my
shirt give myself that like and rip my
pants I've had like Star Spangled
[__] hot pads like a little steering
wheel that was my big closer of course
yeah
I thought it was so and by the way it
would do well of course yeah when it
didn't do well it's one of the most
humiliating things
experiencing your entire [__] life
it's like when you're fourth grade and
you like you don't shake and you're you
have a pee stain and you're and your
gray shorts your gray pleated shorts
yeah it was embarrassing as [__] when it
didn't work so I don't know I don't know
how long I did that but I remember I was
literally like I think one point I took
a pair of jeans I went down to the
Fashion District I'm like can you have
like can you like Stitch the velcros
they look like jeans look at you know
you have to wear them every show
like you have a wardrobe no you have to
rip off at some point stupid but that
was my you know that was my foray and
that was how I started everything was
like I had so many I wasn't like a prop
comic but I did a lot of [__] that like
involved
you know one of the only one of the bits
I did that got sort of viral it's not
hugely viral but back in the day it was
a bit about going to a gay gym and
turning gay again I did the shirt flip
and I would pull out like a red thong
strap oh she'd have to wear the red
thong every show yeah when I first did I
would wear like an actual red thong and
I'd be like Jesus Christ my dick is
getting chopped up and then I just cut
it made like a strap like cut the bottom
and like put it like straps so you have
to wear it every day like going going to
the open mic here we go so the worst is
like you know you're in like Topeka and
you're at a Walmart looking for thongs
for your show and you're in your 30s
you're like what the [__] have I done
with my life I'm coming the kids section
at [__] Target
looking for a red thong strap for a joke
that works most of the time what's goody
Hopper at the verse if you're loving
this episode and all the other awesome
content you get here for free then you
are going to love our brand new hot
breath VIP list all you gotta do to join
is go to hot breathpodcast.com VIP and
you're gonna get exclusive access to not
just podcasts but also other content
like unseen interviews merch drops
discounts giveaways and a lot more
exciting things and this is for everyone
if you're an aspiring or working
comedian or just a comedy fan that loves
getting those behind the scenes nuggets
You're Gonna Love what we have here at
the new hot breath VIP list so go to the
link in the description or join at hot
breathpodcast.com VIP and I'll see you
there speaking of Comedy I've got a
shout out the network behind this show
big laugh comedy they have been killing
it and the Texas comedy scene producing
some of the biggest shows live and also
podcasts like the one you're watching
here and even bigger news big laugh is
hitting the road bringing their best
comedians and shows to a city like yours
so do yourself a favor join their VIP
newsletter and get exclusive access to
not just when they're coming to your
city but also even more fun content and
even comedy news so all you got to do is
go to blcomedy.com VIP HB or hit the
link in the description we'll see you
there how early in your career was this
like how this is last year
no I did this I mean it was probably I
guess it was it that was my gay gym bit
was my first big closer I mean you can
see it it's still
look it's a solid joke don't get me
wrong it still works but um and every
once while I swear to God out of nowhere
I'll be I'll be you know somewhere and I
just and people who I really respect
like like people like a blondes of bone
like you gotta retire that joke man I'm
like okay I don't respect everyone more
than you so I agree but um I would uh
sometimes I'll go show people hey dude
you gotta do the [__] gay gym bed
it's my favorite Becky I'm like I'm not
really going to [__] buy a red thong
you should just get a tattoo of like a
red strip like right here on your hip
you can just pull up every time you need
it
yeah just a red Sharpie that was a good
guy last night who had the America
tattoo I'm like I hope that wasn't for
the bit but but so this is how far I
went with that [__] so I was like how
could I go farther so I used to so I did
this joke about
in general jokes about gay [__] the gym
is just kind of hacky at this point but
I did a joke where I said um
the guy the guy who's always you know
like he puts on every like his shirt his
watch his socks his Dick's still hanging
out
he's always like um I forgot what the
joke was some of my tattoos I go
he said something like
somebody oh
he goes why do you have a handsome
tattoo
I forgot how I said the joke so the
person I was like why do you have a
handsome tattoo and I was like dude quit
quit staring at my lower back
so that was kind of the punch line right
about how gay is it to have a handsome
tattoo in your lower back and sure
enough I would get people with a sharpie
to write Hanson on my lower back gosh
like with with like a stencil I had like
a Hanson stencil no like I requested
that much you made a stencil
no this is just me
[Laughter]
but it was like so I so it was like what
what more can you do so I do the thread
thong and now turn around I have hands
in my lower back as like a as like a
call back
and then again it would it was it's one
of those things you know how it is in
comedy some stuff that that does well
isn't the stuff that you should be doing
yeah
you know and and I always go back and
forth on that because one level I'm like
yeah but there's integrity and there's
Artistic integrity in your true voice
and sometimes like you're just a clown
just go out there and make people laugh
who the [__] cares how you do it hump a
stool for 20 minutes straight if that
kills do it I Feel Like Comics get
really arrogant
like there's some sort of like academic
intellectual about this [__] well you
know the comp like they have like a
[__] brand look the way I do might
come is I break the shut the [__] up
you're a [__] Dancing Clown that's
what we are quit trying to be [__]
irrigated by a comedy like I love Dave
Chappelle and I love that he has social
justice I love all these people but at
the same time like
when Comics come to me like I want to be
more like Dave Chappelle I'm like that's
great he's a [__] goat most people
think I go he's also a clown I mean Dave
should be with his voice I mean he's
he's goofy yeah he does a lot of goofy
[__] Lucia gets a lot of goofy [__] some
of the best Comics you respect the most
they're up there doing a lot of goofy
[__] I mean George Carlin's opener used
to be like you know the hardest job in
the world must be a police sketch artist
in China which like by today's standards
is pretty [__] hacky you know so but
it worked he thought it was funny people
thought it was funny so I kind of have
kind of given up the whole idea of that
there's a right and a wrong way to do it
whatever you do whatever gives you Joy
and as long as you're making the
audience laugh for the most part it
doesn't matter what you do I don't care
I don't care if you're doing the hack is
physical props Jeff Dunham puppets
whatever the [__] it is if it works it
works yeah I've given up on that whole
idea of
finding your voice in the right way or
the wrong way it's just you know I mean
a lot of stuff I used to do would really
kill I don't do anymore
like like being a black crowd like hey
you ever been with the white guy you
know what to say once you go white your
vagina stays tight and it would [__]
murder yeah yeah yeah yeah and I'd find
a White Guy the one white guy once you
go pale you never have to post bail high
five why would you high five that you
racist piece of [__] it would [__] to
this day I could go to chocolate sundae
and I'll [__]
race stuff and I want to [__] I'm
white like all that like I had and I I
started doing it so much I had to get
away from it because I've used it as a
crutch because it um all I have to do is
dab and they're like that white boy
crazy you know but what I've learned is
like that's one level of laughter but
then it's not like that's all they laugh
at the rest of my marriage stuff
like it's not like oh I have to dance it
up it's like do what you do everywhere
and it'll translate yeah yeah that I
agree with you for the most part you
know I was supposed to do uh Kevin
Hart's he has uh Comedy Central
so-called Next Level it was a half hour
specials and I was tapped to do it and I
was
getting ready to do it and they're like
we need to you know there's someone who
is on the fence about you now I'm like I
signed my contract you're already paying
me [__] so what are you talking
about we need you to do a half hour at
Comedy Union
um to prove that you're I was like
and at that point I was so like in this
thing like I'm gonna do what I want to
do at that time whatever it was like
seven years ago or something I was I
wanted to talk about vegans
and it was a lot I mean for like a
better word it was a lot of white [__]
you know but I didn't want to do the the
stuff I'd been doing at chocolate
Sundays I didn't want to do all the
crazy white boy let me let me do my
impersonation black a drunk black woman
I didn't want to do that stuff
and um and so I ended up losing the gig
because of it because I refused I was
like I'm not gonna [__] you already
paid me if you don't like [__] it
and then I look back I'm like oh that
was dumb
like what what mountain was I trying to
die on you know what I mean you didn't
go to Comedy Union and perform your
vegan stuff no I said no I said no you
can you can if you want to hire me you
already hired me I signed the paperwork
you got to pay me so
what do you why are you making me do it
and no one else do it mm-hmm
I took a stand and they [__] replaced
me which is it's fine I mean like that
show was not a very great show but um
but still it would have been a Kevin
Hart sponsored comedy comedy central
special yeah
um so yeah there's lots of shitty
mistakes like that you're making my life
for like I'm not good like I just asked
a comic to open for me in uh hyenas
and Dallas I'm not gonna name his name
Ryan Joseph and he said
and the owner of the club was like okay
can I go I know Ryan's pretty can you
speak be on the just for 15 minutes can
you be clean it's clean it's PG
so I feel like if you've been doing
comedy for more than three years you
gotta have at least 50 minutes of clean
it may not be the [__] that you want to
do but you should be your best [__] yeah
but you gotta have something Whole Foods
is weird something yep no man that's not
who I am I'm a [__] it I'm like
okay drive off in your little 84 Celica
bro so there's you know we gotta sell
out in this business yeah even if you're
not a clean comic having a clean set you
can just get booked more if you're clean
100 like you can just that's just
economics I mean it is hard for me to be
clean I will say that but I'm saying you
have some clean in there like yeah
I just got offered a thousand dollars to
do to do uh a headlining clean set but
it was like the next day
likes for me to really like put together
like 45 minutes clean right now
I need like a good solid [__] week oh
man I'll do it who books it I wish I'd
known you at the time I would have
totally offered it to you I was like 45
minutes I'd also have to fly there it
was just a lot I was like uh I don't
know oh yeah there's a lot that yeah
also my definition of clean may not be
someone else's definition of clean yeah
everyone's is different because
offensive and because offensive can be
clean and clean can be offensive you're
not using it you're not saying [__] or
something like that but what but the
content can be pretty harrowing so yeah
you know what are some it's just I wanna
because you've been doing comedy said 17
years I started 2006. did you start in
New York or in New York you started New
York because I know you did Broadway
yeah you start New York and then moved
to LA to like become an actor was that
hold my beer
there's a long story I owned an
apartment in in Manhattan and I had uh
and I was doing Airbnb because you know
everyone I would rent to they were
artists they're always traveling I did
Airbnb and my Co-op
um wanted to uh evict me I I owned this
apartment because I was doing like um I
did like break dance videos in Spain
yeah because you grew up break dancing
right yeah and they would make me like
they would they get they gave me like so
much [__] so I looked back it was like
my first year out of school it was like
here's 80 grand for these commercials
like yeah that's what it is man this is
my life this [__] actor so I you know
got this apartment when they were cheap
in [__] Hell's Kitchen and um and
then of course the whole neighbor
gentrified and now I have this like
sweet apartment I didn't want to lose
but they didn't want nothing to do with
me and the people I was bringing around
and you know
all married couples and hot women are
coming back to my place and my my
roommate because it's like a 1200 square
foot apartment like real two bedroom two
bath my roommate was an Italian Pinto
named Giorgio and he was always bringing
these beautiful they hated us so the
Airbnb was an excuse to evict me and I
hired a lawyer who ended up being like a
um uh
con artist
this guy named Kent gubrud Kent gub red
he was uh he he just basically like
stole money from me he put a lien in my
apartment
so he kind of like robbed me blind and
so I lost my place
yeah it was brutal I lost like I mean I
shouldn't say numbers but I lost by half
million so I came to um like everything
I'd work for and then I came to
LA and Jamie Masada who's my homie you
know owned her Laugh Factory Laugh
Factory yeah but they got a little place
here it was like teeny like 180 square
foot like is it you shove it you shove a
bed in there
and that's it and I was like this is
where this is like in LA where you think
of the people who ends up like with the
[__] needle in their arm like I could
have made it like I'm like that's where
people go for that to happen
but I like you know I fixed up I made I
made a little yard and
put it together and I love that place I
still [__] live there so that's kind
of where I moved kind of La sort of out
of necessity after losing my place
um but uh so it wasn't ever like I'm
gonna finally [__] go to the big
leagues
yeah exactly I've been going back and
forth my parents they moved from
Virginia out to Huntington Beach so
they're out there now I have a brother
in Santa Barbara so it was kind of like
uh
the first Club I passed will Gotham and
Laugh Factory Gotham but but uh yeah so
the Laugh Factory in New York was there
from 2000
six five to
2009 maybe so that close all this [__]
was happening I was like I guess it's
time just to go to LA
um you know and I I kind of think it's
the same thing I mean look if you could
be in New York and you're past at the
cellar and you're passed at the stand
and you're just you have that you have
that to you and you just go and do seven
shows and I I mean there's no no better
place to be as a comic you know L.A
can't compete with that I mean La you
can do like improv Laugh Factory Comedy
Store and that's kind of you know that's
for the most part it then you maybe go
across the hill and do haha
origami magic but there's but in New
York you can do like literally like
seven shows yeah and there's a real
great Community there and I just never
you know I've never been a hanger outer
so I never really tapped I've also never
been like a roaster Ah that's not for me
all that aggression ah yeah I've never I
don't know if I'm a beta cuck I don't
know what it is but I just I've never
been into roasting I did one roast one
time and this is why because remember
back in the day Jeff Frost would say
well we roast who we love that's
[__] I know for a fact that's a
bunch of hot garbage
that Original Rose crew of all those
[__] they all hate each other
now
huh they all do [__] uh well Joel
just dead but um Lisa Lampanelli Jeff
Ross who's the other Republican guy
Republican guy uh [__] uh New York uh
oh Nick de Paul Nick Apollo all those
original guys they [__] hate each
other man wow roasting is a it's a it's
a very dark energy I'm not saying you
shouldn't do it
and and some people really sued to it
but like there's a I see a lot of
relationships I remember when uh do you
remember when Mike Lawrence and Ralphie
May Heather Rose battle yes yes yes
um I mean Ralphie May never talked to
Mike Lawrence again after that until the
day you died
and I just think that's like
man this is that's intense energy man
it's just not for me yeah I was never
like that when I was I was like you know
captain my soccer team and [__] and I
just never wanted to
[__] with the freshmen you know so every
time I see I just kind of I get like a
little like oh
yeah I did I used I I would do like
roasts I I won a few for like money and
then I I taped comedy Central's roast
battle when they came to Atlanta yeah uh
actually against Dolce Sloan who I
started with
um back in the dizzy and um they ended
up they ended up editing me out like
Dolce and eyes didn't make it they had
another tall white guy and black chick
up in New York so that I guess for
casting you know they do these shows and
they to tell a story and they already
had our characters I guess so they
edited us out of the Final Cut which I
was so grateful for in hindsight but
it's like after I taped that I was like
I mean roasting was cool and like it
worked but it's like it's not it didn't
really make me feel good yeah you know I
didn't I didn't really like what it was
like attracting and I was like I don't
want to be known for that so I was
grateful that ended up getting edited
out of it yeah and edited out of a few
things where I was like this is it and
then hindsight you're like oh maybe I'm
glad that that wasn't yeah for sure for
sure and don't get me wrong I'm I'm also
not great at it there are people who
have like a real ability like Lawrence
is a great like they're people who have
a real knack for it and I just uh I
don't look for it so it doesn't I did
one roast with a girl who used to open
for me and like again after that we just
kind of fell out of touch coincidentally
yeah you know what I mean yeah these are
things you kind of learn like what are
what are things you wish you knew when
you started that maybe would have made
your journey easier or maybe well the
funny thing is one things I learned
early on and um
I've always known this
was that uh
and we talked about this right before
the podcast is comedy is really kind of
about the hang you know so if you're a
real gregarious you can be in social
situations you can talk to people hang
out and drink and smoke just be the fun
guy like a like a Joe De Rosa guy is
great hang
um your career is is
right there for you you know if you have
any ability and any work ethic at all
and you're a great hang and you don't
kill yourself with drugs and alcohol
like the business is right it's
wide open for you you know truly
um and I knew that going in people's hey
you got to hang out more you got to do
FaceTime the concert you did it and I
was I just never
and and not because I was like I'm too I
just I've always had like a little I've
never been very social I don't know if I
have social anxiety or what but I just
kind of in general I'm just like I want
to be home watching ESPN with my dick in
my hand right now I don't want to be
sounds very social yeah so so I mean no
I I've been social but I just kind of
like I don't know it was it was weird I
kind of I I maybe insecurity I just
wouldn't hey come come to the seller and
hang out you know there are people who
sit there at those tables the seller and
they just get like lambasted by like
Rich Voss and Patrice O'Neill for like
years and years and years until they
finally like earned their stripes and
that just was never appealing to me
maybe it's like the white trash man I
was like if someone flew I'm gonna
[__] knock someone out I mean
literally there's an apartment that's
like like that Waterboy switch in the
Adam Sandler movie I'm like I'm like
yeah two degree but then also shut the
[__] up you know what I mean
so but there are people who are just
great with that and uh I knew that going
in and it was never really
I think I had a belief that if I really
worked hard as an actor and I was making
it as an actor that it would logically
flow into like more stand-up
but the worlds actually don't really
intertwine that way they don't really go
from acting to stand up
you can be a massive actor
and getting stand up and people like huh
they don't care so you have to be
it's better to be a good stand-up than
is be a good actor you can be a great
stand-up I mean you can be a great
Stanley Andrew Schultz and get like
acting roles even though he can't act
lick you know what I mean I don't mean
that in a bad way but did you see his
last movie I mean I cannot it's fine you
don't have to be a good actor just get
in the bag you know but but you're great
he's an incredible stand-up so it's they
will they will give you that license you
can you can be a great stand-up
and you can book more than an actor who
spent their whole life studying acting
because it's not that hard a discipline
to say lines you know and stand up
you're you're in control of in terms of
like like you said with acting there's
auditions there's different variables
but like if you get really good at stand
up I feel like at some point you'll
build some sort of audience that you can
sell tickets to or sell patreon to or
something absolutely acting there's a
lot more variables but stand up I think
that's why a lot of stand-ups still they
become famous Beyond it still do stand
up because it is like the stability that
like well no one can take this for me
this over years and I think if you talk
to most people who who have like split
careers and stand up and act like Judah
friedlander who is an incredible actor
and he's a great actor that guy if
you've ever seen him in like American
Splendor and stuff
um obviously 30 Rock but you know you
asked you a free learner like if you had
to choose one he would say not not a
question stand up yeah I don't think
most
it is weird because then if you look at
the really like the top one percent you
look at like Eddie Murphy Steve Martin
some of the people who really Jim Carrey
they just stopped doing stand-up and I
also get that too you know what I mean
because now you're stay you're like one
of the most famous people in the world
and you're doing stand-up and everyone's
gonna be like
you better show why you're the most
famous person in the [__] world and
if and if your relationship was stand-up
was always kind of like a little
gimmicky
I don't want to like speak ill of Steve
Martin he's a legend but like a little
gimmicky then like your gaming started
it yeah he he went the exact opposite
direction comedy was very serious and
very political and he flipped it on its
head and created this whole new style of
Comedy that now and hindsight maybe yeah
but at the time it had never been done
before but then when you're now there
you're super famous everyone see you put
a [__] fake arrow through your head
and go like I'm a Wilding crit he was
just like I'd rather kill myself I mean
that's kind of what he wrote in this
book right he's like [__] that I can't
have people yelling at him he was too
fat yeah he got two fans too famous with
a lot of those people Eddie Murphy you
know Jim Carrey A lot of these guys who
just go they get so famous that like
when you're a stand-up it's almost like
you can't really
be authentic anymore or something I
don't know what it is but like really
the people who hit the Pinnacle of
success and TV and film they they kind
of drop out of Comedy which has always
been an interesting thing to see yeah I
would I would definitely like to do
acting I've done some but I haven't it's
like one of those things like I'd like
to do that all right what are you doing
to do it well nothing you know but but
but also at the same time like that is
how people get a producer will see you
at a show and be like you're great you
act here's a part I want you to audition
for it I mean a lot of these I I see
every day I see uh shows on Netflix
where Comics are playing big roles and
like I know they've never acted before
but they but someone saw them and they
like what was like beef I think there
was a bunch of comics on that role
um I see I see it all the time and I get
it there are some directors like Steven
Soderbergh loves Comics he always hires
Comics who've never acted before in his
stuff so um so I think that there's
always opportunity I mean you know Tony
Hinchcliffe has got an acting roles just
from his comedy as well and I don't know
if he's anymore but he was so I think um
I think that's a better path so just
keep doing stand-up and then it'll I
mean you could do like yeah if people
say how would you get into it it's like
[__] hell I mean I guess if you have
an agent or a manager just say hey can
you send me out for something the good
thing now is now that covet happened
everything's just self tape you don't
have to go into a room that's much
better [__] that look like you
they're giving you the hairy eyeball
like trying to Mad Dog you out
you're like a guy or like shangillis
does where he shoots his own sketches
puts them online and they go viral I
mean Jesus that's a way to do it too
absolutely yeah I've always so the one
advice I would give people
other than just hanging out you know
just hang out with people be fun be nice
to everybody be nice to everybody amen
everybody I cannot tell you how many
people I've worked with that are
Headliners that big big time people or
it just comes back to you man you know
it always so be just be nice to the door
people the sway staff the openers the MC
because you never [__] not not just
for selfish reasons because but you just
should it's a hard [__] life that
we're even at the successful end of it
it's a [__] hard life you set
yourself up for a lot of like pain and
disappointment humiliation a lot of
times you give up families you give up
the idea of a family you give up your
marriage you give up a normal regular
life just for this crazy drug of chasing
you know the stage so I think that you
just be nice to all the people all the
you know the people when people come up
to me and they're I've been doing it for
two years and I'm a fan of you or
something that's that's [__] amazing
that's great uh well you should have
better taste but hey man like thanks for
thanks for approaching me so um yeah
that's be nice and also just like learn
how to edit
like get proficient with with Final Cut
get proficient with editing [__] because
particularly now the game is is that and
I and I'm a little bit of a boomer but I
feel that um and I could have learned
that [__] any step of the way for the
past 10 years I'm like if only I knew
how to edit well you could have I could
have learned I never did it's not too
late yeah I know even now I'm like I'll
be six like I should have started when I
was 45. anyway um so I think that you
should definitely learn a modicum of
editing skills because the truth is yeah
ABC NBC they're all Studios but you know
also the studio [__] YouTube this is
Studio it's your own Studio you can make
anything with a [__] iPhone you can
make
I mean Joey Medina me and Jeremy and
Eric Blake we made this little short
film called Beautiful violence
this one like a hundred and
70 Awards in the short film I mean I
don't think is that good but it won all
these Awards I've won like 15 acting
Awards which again not a big deal but
like it says in my MD he's won 15 acting
Awards so it's something so I just think
that and that was just like iPhones and
and Ally one night we shot this thing
out so there's so much opportunity to
create work if you're a Creator and you
have a creative mind there's so much
[__] opportunity out there for very
little money and most people just they
just already count themselves out before
they even start like oh how do you do it
well
this is how you do it you have a phone
and you have a brain that's all you need
that's all you need you can create
anything you can just sit there turn the
phone on I remember I was talking to
David Arnold recipes amazing man dude
you know he would just and I I
interviewed my podcast about
um
he was just starting to break from
Facebook of all places
and he was like and he would just have
the camera says you know this is my son
my wife does and he would go and it'd be
about the [__] dishwasher or whatever
the [__] it was just simple mundane
everyday stuff of a married man it was
building Billy Bill and it [__] like
blew the [__] up and I asked him I said
he goes you know I was and he was at the
time he started doing he was like 50.
you know he goes look man he goes I've
seen these young kids
out there posting these videos and goes
I can do a minute of funny a day
I can do that I can do something one
minute of funny a day I could do that
that's what all this all it took for him
to start going there and talking about
the stuff in his life and he became a
massive [__] star I mean you can say
overnight success we've been doing it
for [__] 25 years yes
um anyway yeah so there the opportunity
is right there on your [__] phone we
all have iPhones if you have a Samsung
you should probably kill yourself yeah
but uh
you can just yeah you can make it learn
some editing skills you watch YouTube
videos learn the [__] be a good hang be
nice to to everyone and it's right there
I'm the Ghost of Christmas feature I
didn't do any of that [__] but if you do
it but if you do it kids and actually
start I think a lot of times and I think
people will even listen to this show a
lot of the times and learn a lot of
things and then never like actually go
do them type 100 like it's you're
learning and learning at some point you
have to execute and that's when you're
it's like writing all day you never know
to get on that stage absolutely you've
got to actually do it and that's when
you're going to start oh yeah in terms
of stamp people like what what advice
you about stand-up it's the only thing I
say is like well the number one thing is
get on stage well I've been writing
jokes for two years that's too long
get on stage gotta get on stage give
yourself a depth and I literally tell
people I go if you're not on stage it
was like it's June if you're on by July
15th like don't talk to me again don't
keep asking advice seriously because
people will be like for years asking
advice on [__] and I'll be like if
you're not on stage by this time like
don't don't talk to me
because the truth is no matter what you
do first of all that doesn't mean just
because you gotta say it doesn't mean
you're now a stand-up and that's gonna
be your whole [__] life a lot of
people they get on stage they scratch
that itch and they're like that was
awesome
life for me because it's really about
committing to a lifestyle more than is
committing to a career yeah so I uh
but I think it's great for everyone
anyone that [__] plan to get on stage
because you it'll always come in handy
there's always going to be a wedding
where you have to bring a speech there's
always going to be some sort of
corporate event you can maybe do a
funeral who the [__] knows but there's
always an opportunity for you to be on
stage with prepared words and talk to
people in your life so stand up will
help that quite a bit for everyone you
know yeah well Bill you've helped us
today and I appreciate your time I mean
where can people follow you or if people
hear this and feel inspired and want to
reach out to you what's the best way uh
just Instagram billdaws
b-i-l-b-i-l-l-d-a-w-e-s yeah and yeah
please please check out stuff I'm on you
can see Mo I'll be back for season two
of Mo on Netflix great
um and then Alaska Daily watch that
first season Alaska Daily and I'll be in
the new Taylor Sheridan series bass
Reeves coming out in the fall which is
why I got this awful goatee so support
my acting back too
yeah well um well you have a podcast as
well oh you have a podcast called the
afterlife I didn't want to
um yeah and next time you're in L.A
please let's do it I'll def yeah I'll
definitely hit you up okay cool man
awesome thanks Joe Bill dolls thanks for
coming bye guys bye-bye hot breath